- Well, this is a wild question from Marc
because I would argue
that my entire life has been that.
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] You got more perspective.
(engine roaring)
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
- This is gonna be kinda off the rails
to my opportunity to speak to Gary,
I'm gonna ask things that
I'm personally curious about.
So I kinda have this theory
that kinda life has these phases to it.
And for me kinda phase
one was up until I was 30
where I really had no
clue what I was about.
I didn't know what my passion was.
I didn't know really where I was going.
And I was really lucky.
I had this kind of mentor
who kinda grabbed me
and said, "How old are you?"
And I said, "Well, I was 29."
And he goes, "Oh, okay."
He goes, "You don't have far to go."
He goes, "Usually when you hit 30,
all of a sudden everything becomes clear."
And got low and behold, he was right.
Then all of a sudden I could
go, "Oh, I like what I'm doing.
I can see a path from here.
I have family now, I have balance."
And it set up this
wonderful period of my life.
So here's what I was gonna bring up
is that the second period for
me started when I turned 45.
The third period really throw it to 45.
And 45 was the year that I left Netflix.
45 was a little bit after the Netflix IPO.
And it was this real boundary for me
because I so distinctly remember
I went to the IPO, we're in New York,
we were up in the Merrill
Lynch trading floor
and it was kinda anticlimactic.
You know, there was no bells to ring,
no confetti, just kinda
the trading started,
but it was a significant milestone.
And I remember leaving the building
and I was with my
eight-year-old son, Logan.
And we had a New York objective
'cause he grew up on California
as this bronze to me.
And I go, "I'm gonna take him to get
some real New York pizza."
So we're in the cab and we're heading down
from the Merrill building
downtown to go to original Resy
like 80 of them now.
But I remember thinking,
"I could kinda do whatever I want now."
And it was a really weird feeling
'cause you think you have
all these opportunities,
but instead, it's kind of
throws you off balance.
So since in so many ways,
you and I have had these
similar trajectories
and I kinda know, we see
the world the same way
and we have these same
motivations in some ways,
some of the same superpower.
And I know that you just hit 45.
- Yes.
- And I'm wondering,
do you feel that things
are changing for you?
- I do.
And I think things are always changing.
And to your point,
I think round numbers
get people thoughtful.
I think people think differently
around their zero and five birthday
whether it's 20 or 25, 30, 35, right?
For me,
I, as a child spent a lot of time
hanging out with grandparents.
And I've been thinking
about this a lot lately.
I was very gravitated towards,
you know, 70, 80 year olds
when I was 7, 8, 9, 10.
It was just a thing.
I was very close to my great-grandfather
when we first immigrated to America.
Spent a lot of time with him
at the park when I was three, four,
but I remember it.
I literally remember it more.
Maybe it was more for four.
Then we moved to Jersey.
I remember like...
And then definitely
from like 1982 to 1988,
every time a grandparent
would come and visit,
I just always felt this weird association
towards somebody would always
ask them stories, history.
And so I've always felt
in a lot of ways that
in hindsight as I got older,
I was like, "Oh, I'm an old soul.
I like wisdom."
Like, "Oh, I was such a bad student,
but history was something
I was always really..."
The only Bs I had on my report
card on regular classes,
not named Jim we're in history.
And even like my current passion
in discovering what I think
is about to play out with NFTs
and the whole non-fungible
token blockchain.
A lot of it has to do with
psychology and history
and IP and all this stuff.
Things are changing, but not
from a wisdom standpoint.
You know?
I'll give you something tangible.
I've come to realize recently
called last two, three years
that my greatest
vulnerability as a leader,
believe it or not,
because people are confused by this
'cause I'm so candorous on
interviews and on-stage.
But as an operator, I so struggle
with delivering bad news.
Believe it or not that
I've struggled with candor.
And I've created this term
for myself, kind candor.
I've come to realize
that it's a vulnerability
and I wanna be better.
And all of us evolve and
we want to be better,
and kind candor is something
that I've stood up
recently in my own mind.
And now even within VaynerX,
my holding company.
I want people to be able to do that
because it leads to entitlement
and resentment if you're
not deploying candor.
But I think what's happening for me is
I've always in my mind
put a premium on 50 to 60 years old.
I've always, probably
since I was about 19 or 20
started having these feelings
that 50 to 60 was gonna be the money shot.
And so, you know, when you're 26
and thinking about 50 to 60,
you're like, "Oh, my God.
I have a whole life to live
before I even enter my
quote-unquote "Prime".
But now I'm 45,
and I'm like, "Okay, I'm
about to go into this thing
that I've put on a pedestal.
A thing that's been intuitive to me
and I'm excited about it."
I feel like I'm gearing up
and I feel experienced to
go along with the raw talent
that I was gifted with.
And, you know, I've
never lacked confidence
not because I was audacious,
but because my confidence
came from my conviction
of appreciating the
process over the results.
- Yeah, the plunging in.
Just the "Let's do something
and let's see what happens."
- Mm-hmm.
And so I'm pretty excited about this...
- Do you still believe
it's the money shot?
- Yeah, you know, I do feel
like it makes sense to me.
And maybe when I'm 60, I'm
like, "No, wait a minute,
it was 70 that... you know."
But I do think that there's a
time and a place and a prime.
I think I've always felt that
business had more similarities
to sport than people realized.
There's been no athlete that's come along
and has been consistently the same athlete
for all 8, 12, 15 years
of her or his career.
There is a prime and...
- Oh, yeah, I get it.
The thing that I'm trying to curious
and I'll check in with you in five years
and see how it feels is that
the, certainly the skill...
- 10 is gonna be more interested
'cause I'll be in the eye of the storm.
If you check it with me in five years
which I'm happy to do,
I'm gonna be hyped 'cause
I'm like, "Here we go."
- There probably some
time in your schedule
just about freeing up a
9 or 10 years from now.
But you know, it's I do,
I spend as you do a ton
of time with young people,
you know, people who are
still in high school,
people are still in college
and I'm spending a bunch of time
with some TikTok people right now
who have this huge early fame.
And it's funny 'cause they
are very economically focused.
I mean, to them, that's the hurdle.
You try to say
and I never quite know
how it's getting through
that you will see that
there needs to be more to it
than that.
And that what I think of huge
advantage of when we hit 45
and when I hit 45, as you
do have all these skills
and you go, "I know I
can do business stuff,
but now I've gotta be selective
about what I want to apply
these skills to.
What is the business that I want to do?
What is the non-business
that I want to do?
How do I want to use it?"
It's a really kinda interesting struggle.
At least for me of saying...
- I think when you're young
time is your teammate.
- Yes, exactly.
- And I think as you get older,
it's really how the brain works.
When you're seven and you've gotta wait
to your 10th birthday,
you believe you've been
on earth for seven years.
That's half your life.
Like half the life you lived
is what you're anticipating
to be double digits.
But when you get to 45
and one year is a small percent,
like it goes fast, right?
That's how you get...
And so I think that's an
extremely valid point.
One of the things I worry about
is I live in such abundance
that I need to be thoughtful
about my time resource.
And I do feel like I'm
vulnerable to that mistake.
And it is something
that runs subconsciously
and is now become
conscious for me of like,
"Hey, you value the
serendipity and the learning,
and the curiosity so much.
You need to be careful here
because how many more
innings do you have?"
Plenty 'cause I'm a guy that's like,
"I'm going for another 45,"
but you still need to be thoughtful.
And you never know when a rock hits you
in the head and it's over.
And so you gotta be thoughtful.
- It's also, I think that, you know,
I think one of the things
that you and I have in common
is also a huge curse,
is that we see these huge opportunities.
I mean, I know that
that's how you're wired.
It's that almost life arbitrage thing.
And whether it's being at a garage sale
and seeing something I'll go,
"Oh, my God, I can buy that for five bucks
and sell it for 20."
But I see that all the
time, not at garage sales,
but I see that in business opportunities.
Just like with Empathy,
where you go, "Oh my gosh,
there is this opening
for a native direct to consumer brand
and you go, "Fuck, I'm
just gonna create it."
But the thing is those,
especially as you get
better and get more attuned
and get better skills,
those things accelerate.
And that's when you go, "Holy shit,
I've got to back up a little bit.
I've got to realize I've
got to focus a little bit
and kinda pick my battles."
- I literary texted my brother
AJ today, four hours ago,
three hours ago,
"Crippled by opportunity."
That was the text.
- It's tricky. it really is tricky.
And it's so hard.
I personally feel it in all kinds of ways.
I certainly feel it.
I'm so lucky now I get
all kinds of invitations
either to invest or to advise
or to be part of things.
And then it is such a struggle to say, no.
- Especially when you're an
optimist and an entrepreneur,
you're in the yes business.
- I once described it to someone
as it's like someone who's
like walking by on the sidewalk
and seeing a little basket full of puppies
with no one there.
And God, you can't walk by
because someone's got to do this.
And whenever I see an opportunity,
I go, "I just want to do it
and I want to make it real."
And no matter how
unrealistically impossible it is,
it's a really tricky, fun.
I mean, I'm certainly glad
I was gifted with that.
It certainly has worked
out really well for me.
But boy, sometimes I've
really got a struggle
to control myself.
- Yup.
- I got related or somewhat related ones.
So since we brought up Empathy,
so probably you the same.
One of the things I get asked all the time
by entrepreneur is "When do I stop?
How do I know when to give up?"
- I'll save your time.
- I never know freaking
how to answer that.
- It's impossibly difficult question.
The answer is nobody on earth knows.
- So I did a company after
Netflix which was Looker Data,
which we tried to sell.
And I look back,
it's such a 2020 hindsight thing
and you did it 'cause of those information
you have at the time.
And you look back and go,
"Ah, we should have wrote it.
We were on the verge of going public.
Just think what that would have been like
not just as a business,
but as a cultural thing."
And I'm wondering with you
struggle with the same thing
with Empathy, or even
before that with a Resy?
- No, Empathy and Resy were great exits.
They're nine figure type deals.
They were big wins.
I had partners who were operating.
I was more in chairman and founder level.
So I'd never really sold a company
that I'm navigating day to day.
They're both family businesses,
Vayner and Wine Library.
And so I didn't have any regrets
with either because I wasn't the jockey.
I was the inventor of the
horse or a co-inventor,
but I wasn't the jockey.
I might've been the trainer,
And so I don't have those
feelings because of that scenario.
And for everybody who's listening back
to trying to provide value,
my dream of heaven is it'll
show you all the scenarios
'cause I think that'd be really cool.
But other than that,
my make pretend of how
I want heaven to be.
Nobody can ever tell you that
if you held onto it for another month
that X would have
happened and that's cool.
And then there's a million
people who wrote it out
for another three years and got a what?
I mean, you and I have run in circles
where we know incredible horror stories
of people passing on selling their company
for 210 million
only to have it go out of business
or pass and selling it for 44 million
only to have it sold for 19.
Like people always think
of it as a one-way street.
It goes both ways and that's important.
- Oh, it certainly is.
Especially, if you've been
in certainly like I haven't
Silicon Valley for a long time,
you've seen so many horror stories.
It gets drilled into you
that you don't want to bet your whole life
on an uncertain future.
I mean, there's one
thing to have confidence
and it's one thing to take risks,
but certainly, even
the biggest risk takers
do what they can to hedge the risks.
One time, I worked for a
company called Borland,
big software company a long time ago,
was crushing it 'cause
we were looking like
we were gonna overtake Microsoft.
If you can imagine how
ridiculous the assumption was
back then.
But I had stock options
and they were worth a lot of money.
And I was in a bar in Hong
Kong with our VP of sales
on some sales tour, just to
put a crazy scenario here.
And I was going, "God, this
stock price is going great."
And he goes, "Yeah, I
hope you're selling."
And I go, "Selling, why
would I want to sell?
It's like, it's going up and up and up."
And he goes, "No, you
are out of your mind."
He goes, "Every time
your stock vests, sell."
And he goes, "You'll
always have more coming
than you sold.
And if you're doing a great job,
they'll keep giving you more.
But if you don't sell anything,
your downside is unlimited.
You could go to zero.
All you're doing is taking
slight caps on your upside."
And Ben, from that moment,
that was a long time ago.
Every single chance I
get, I try and hedge.
I mean, even with Looker
as that was going up.
Every chance, every round,
we'd sell into the round a little bit.
Just to take a little bit
of money off the table
and go, "I have no idea
what's going to happen,
but at least I have
something for my efforts."
- I accept.
There's the other side of it.
I was early into Facebook,
but not as early as the
original 102 employees.
A lot of those kids sold Facebook
at 19 when it hit the floor at 25 and 27.
That was a mistake.
Some of those people were
thrilled to get the $10 million.
The problem is 10 times
that it's a hundred.
And so, you know, there's
a lot of ways to play it.
- Yeah. I think the real key
is you just can't look back.
You can't worry about this stuff.
It's unknowable.
You just got to move on and you go,
"There'll be more fun yet to come."
And I think the same people
who are always worried
about what could have been,
and I don't want to do this,
and I make the wrong decision.
The people who were
scared to move forward.
Another great thing that you
and I kinda have in common
is this whole most advancement
comes from just starting,
just doing something.
Stop, stop thinking.
I don't know how long ago
this was, you did that, what?
7 or 800 page slide deck
about how to do 60 some odd
pieces of social media in a day.
And I remember it was one line in there,
something that goes...
"The thing that gets everyone in trouble
is they have this standard
of production value."
- Correct.
- And so they just spend the
whole time tweaking fonts
and rather than just
fucking putting it out there
and then moving onto the next one.
And that's so much more powerful.
And God, that's something
that I've done with time
and time and time again is trained myself
that I'm totally okay shit.
I'm totally okay.
Testing something that has broken links
and it has bad images.
You learn nothing from something perfect
that never sees the night and day.
- I always say you can't
read about doing pushups.
- (laughing) Yeah.
I have a similar one.
I go, "You can't learn to play
tennis by watching a video."
- That's it.
That's it.
Exactly right.
- Yeah. You got it.
That was some over sharing.
The other one is basically
"The key to success is being willing
to seem like you're a five-year-old."
- You know, it's funny you say that.
I'm writing a new book
and that will be out
probably in the winter.
And curiosity is a very big theme in it.
- Yeah.
- I really believe that that
has helped me quite a bit.
- With curiosity, it's
not knowing in advance
what can't be done
and it's being willing
to look like an idiot.
- Humility. Humility.
- You speak any languages,
but you wanna learn French,
You gotta sound like you're five years old
for a couple of years.
And being willing to go
into restaurants and say
"I can't speak, but I'm gonna try."
And that's how I'm gonna learn,
- Humility.
- It's a big one too.
It's funny.
I'm very hot on those.
Keep going.
- No, it's cool.
I mean, as you probably know,
I'm trying to follow in the Gary V path.
I have a podcast just when you're going.
I'm not gonna interview for the podcast,
but I'm going to do a kind of a podcast
and mostly, not one where I interview
really successful entrepreneurs
'cause that's been done,
and done way better than I could do it.
But kinda doing much more
along the ask Gary V stuff
where I work with and mentor people,
which I've been doing for 15 years
and now I'm just recording it,
but it's called "That'll Never Work".
And one of the things
I was curious about...
One of my premises is
that every single person
who does something new, here's that.
You all come rushing
in and tell your wife,
"That'll never work."
You tell your investors,
And I'm sure you've heard
that a hundred times.
And I wonder if there's some
of those that really stand out
in your mind when someone
told you that'll never work
and what you were thinking at the time?
- Well, this is a wild question from Marc
because I would argue
that my entire life
has been that.
(laughing)
- I mean...
I've been innovating my whole career.
You know, I was a bad student,
so from day one, I was told
I would never be anything
by the establishment outside of my mom.
You know?
So that was good 'cause
it made me not scared.
- Right.
- You know, like by the
time I became a grownup,
I was told.
But the one place I was never told that
was that the consumer level.
At the lemonade stand, at
the baseball card show,
and my dad's liquor store, I was shining.
The consumer always said yes to me,
but humans who had judgment
of what I was up to
always said, no.
I'm going through it right now.
The last two weeks I've
been explaining to everybody
what I'm gonna do in NFTs.
Now I have some reputation,
so people are a little bit more
thoughtful with their nose.
- (laughing) They hedge their bets.
- But I mean, my dad
was told by every liq...
All these uncles of mine,
other liquor store owners
that grew up knowing,
they all told my dad he was crazy
for letting me build a website.
The internet was a fad, 1996, it's a fad.
How can you spend $25,000, 15 on the side
and then a little to kick it off them?
That was a lot of money
for a small business
that does 300,000 in profit a year.
And you know, building
winelibrary.com was crazy.
Moving all the money from
print and direct mail
to Google AdWords was crazy.
Now I'd built this $40
million company from four
and now I'm spending all my
time in this thing called
YouTube and making videos.
Who do I think I am?
What is this? That's crazy.
Then my financial
advisor said it was crazy
that I put all my money that I'd saved
into Facebook and Twitter stock.
That was crazy.
Starting an advertising agency
by being a wine merchant.
That was crazy.
You know, buying Bitcoin
in 2014 was crazy.
I mean nothing, nothing...
I don't really remember anything
I was excited about that
wasn't met with blind.
You can do it from my mom
and then probably not from everybody else.
That's a story of my life.
- I've kind of learned
that my wife is almost
a reverse indicator.
That if she goes, "Uh, what?"
I go, "I am onto something."
- I love it.
- Yeah, it's true.
I mean, gosh, it's such
a huge piece of knowledge
for anyone to gather,
which is that no one else knows anything
that they're all just
kinda using these patterns
they've learned from other things
and trying to handicap
where there's something new
is actually gonna work or not.
And so it's so much easier to go,
"That'll never work because
they're probably gonna be
right more times than not."
But it's just such a terribly
de-motivating piece of advice.
- It's happening to me right now.
As I explained to people
that NFTs is gonna be
the ultimate arbitrage for influencers
that have build real communities.
The way that artists are gonna
get their actual economics.
The fact that people will
care about social currency
at scale, virtual goods.
You know, these are all
things that I believe in,
and it's hard for people to understand.
I have to say things to them like
"How much do you think three years ago
at the height of it, two years
ago at the height of it?"
Somebody would pay for a
blue check on Instagram
And however I storytell that,
a lot of people are like,
"Oh, a lot."
And well, that's what NFTs is gonna be.
They're like, "Oh, wait a minute.
I can take a screenshot of it."
I'm like, "You can also
have a fake Prada bag.
You're allowed to buy a fake Rolex."
You know, people struggle with new things.
They don't understand the blockchain.
They don't understand these things.
I mean, this is why I love
having a relationship with you.
I used to go crazy
with people about Netflix
versus Blockbuster.
- (laughing) Me too.
- Yes, but you had a lot more financial
and emotional reasons too.
I saw it from a hundred
fuckin' miles away.
It just was obvious to me.
- And listen, and not to
be kissing your ass here,
but seriously, I was a
wine person a long time ago
and I was a direct marketing guy.
And when I saw what you were doing,
I was going, "Oh Jesus, this is...
I can't believe he's the first person
who's kinda building this out."
It's so evident to me.
And same with Jeff Bezos,
I'll go, "They're not nuts.
It just so evident to me."
- I don't know if you can see this.
You're about to see some goose...
I literally, literally
there have been three
companies that I've ever
bought public stock of
ever in my entire life over-the-counters.
You know, what's funny about me?
I don't want the money.
I want the happiness.
I don't get great joy in buying stock.
One of the reasons I love
NFT is I love to doodle.
(laughing)
Yeah, people didn't know this about me.
So like this speaks to me.
I've always been obsessed with Walt Disney
and Vince McMahon. Why?
IP creation.
The Macho Man and Hulk Hogan
are Goofy and Mickey Mouse,
I get it.
And so this is gonna be
a great space for me,
but the reason you just said
Bezos and I got goosebumps
is Amazon, Netflix, and
Shopify are the three companies
that I've bought.
Every other public share I own
is 'cause I invested in a
lot of private companies
that went public.
I'm about to have a big one with Coinbase.
I'm gonna have those shares,
but it's not because I'm
buying them on the open market.
And by the way, I probably should
'cause I've been very right
about a lot of companies.
It's just not where I get
my excitement, but I get it.
It's very obvious to me.
- Yeah. It's such a great thing.
It makes life exciting.
You should makes it fun.
It's being able to see these
things happening and go.
Here's what I thinks gonna to
go down and having it go down,
it doesn't get much better than that.
- By the way, be the historical rep,
the historical correctness
is what I live for.
- Is what you, what?
- It's what I live for.
- Oh, I know.
- I liked it.
I liked it. It's a fun game.
Are you better at seeing it than others?
It's a real business
challenge for thought leaders
and thinkers and pontificator and debaters
and curiositors, like that's my game.
- Yeah. And I think in this
game that we play so much of it
comes down to this, I'll
call it informed instinct,
which is that you go,
"There's all this stuff in my head
and I can't draw the dots for you.
I can't necessarily lay it all logically,
but it's lining up
and something is telling me
it's going to go this way."
And then people go, "Oh,
he's a good guesser."
And it is.
But it's also trusting this impulse
that something's gonna happen
is actually gonna happen.
That once you learn to
trust yourself on that,
it's such a great way to sort out
all these possible things
you could be doing.
Well, cool. Listen, I
know I got to lose you
in a second to stay and
keep you on your schedule.
One really last question.
You have so much shit going
on and I hear you say,
"The balance is so important."
Do you have any certain
trick you use to try
and keep your head from exploding
from making sure you have a
have time for the other stuff?
- Not judgment.
- Not what?
- Not judging myself.
- Yeah.
That's a good one.
- A lack of judgment
on yourself allows you
to not judge others, which is healthy.
And it also makes you not dwell,
which allows you to drop 33 plates
while you've got 86 in a year,
and you're still thrilled with
your net positive outcome.
- In that, looking back
at historical correctness,
people only remember that
one plate you managed
to keep going and they
forget about the other 79.
- 1000%.
And if you have the humility
to respect your craft...
I love entrepreneurship,
not 'cause it's money,
but because it's fair.
- Yeah.
- When I lose, I deserve it.
And I like it.
- True.
- I liked that I passed on Uber twice.
I liked that I bought some
Bitcoin at 14, but not enough.
I liked my losses.
- Yup. There's some of the
plates you drop and that's fine.
It's part of the nature of it.
Closest to a meritocracy we're gonna find.
- Yes. That's true.
- Well, cool.
Listen, thanks so much for
squeezing half an hour with me.
Good luck, and hopefully
we can get a chance to see
each other face-to-face in
the not too distant future.
- Talk to you soon.
- All right. See you, Gary.
- Bye-bye.
You do botcher.
What's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you,
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to explode.
Stories, polls, more
content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.